so for a donor walk with ninja home from
timber university and piano from
Cheyenne university of finance and
economics sorry sir okay then a loader
so I've start with the problem of County
matchings and this is of fundamental
importance to this work so it's a well
known problem and it is shopping hard
and we know there is the FP proud to
come approximate the country number of
legends and so I think for this all
interview I don't need to explain what
is a FP r us and so a very general
method to design approach is to first
decide as Emperor that can uniform in
semper from the set of merchant in a
graph and then there's a general
procedure to transform the same /
temperature after us so in light of this
gentleman sting cloud define the most
welcome change to a uniform example from
the set of all merchants so I am going
to describe this mountain chain first
because the main culprit of these
workers to generalize this Markov chain
to other accounting problems so suppose
now we are at some matching m and we are
going to decide what is the next the
matching M Prime in the next step so the
Mach 10 worked at as follows so first it
is Lady Luck of chain so with
probability one-half we we we have M
prime equal to em and otherwise we can
to randomly choose an edge e equal to UV
and there are four cases so suppose this
is our current the current matching
where we are at so if E is just the edge
in the matching then we can remove this
match from the front from m and obtain
our new new matching impromptu this
operation color remove and similarly we
will have to
other operations at a new edge and
replaced the edge by a new edge so this
is the Malcolm chain and we are
interested in the mixing time of this
Markov chain so we have to fix my
notation so in the following we are
working on a graph with n vertices and
we use omega to denote the family of all
matching theme in this graph and we use
try to did note the uniform distribution
and all we also use this P to denote the
transition matrix of the train and we
can define what is recorded wrapped in
mixing so I think both of us are winning
with these definitions and in order to
prove Malcolm chain is rep mixing we are
very useful technique you still to
define so-called the canonical passes so
we can look at the configuration graph
of this of this matching so in the
configuration graph each vertex is our
matching the support we are working our
graph with of all with four vertices so
so this is the configuration graph and
we have an edge between a pair of
matching tip we can move from these
merchants to the other in one step in
our Markov chain and we say a canonical
path is so for each pair of matching we
want to define a set of passage from X
to Y such an end we want to apply a
weight to each of this path and this
part this weight are required to satisfy
this equation that is for every so for
every pair of matching x and y the
summation of weight of paths connecting
XY might be the same as the pi of x x
power of Y so if we we have a set of a
passive satisfy this requirement then we
say the familiar of this part of the
canonical path for this Markov chain ok
so and so what do
by a good canonic pass intuitive it
means that we will not design a this
path distributed aboriginal over all the
configurations so we can consider the
the notion of congestion of the edge so
we can consider our edge in the
configuration graph so so each edge is a
pair of matching and we can consider the
summation of all the parties crossing
the stage the dimensional the summation
of all the weight of a particle to the
edge over the competitive be is defined
as the congestion of this edge and the
congestion of a and the congestion of a
canonical part is the maximal congestion
/ or the edge so and we we know that if
we can somehow define a canonical part
which whose congestion is funded by some
polynomial then we can show this Malcolm
change its regularly mixing so this is
what we know and and in the vector which
is quite the economic part for the
Jeremy and Sinclair chain for temple
images so and then I will talk about how
to generalize this to other problems so
consider now we have a pair of matchings
in the configuration graph so this is M
and M Prime the first thing we do is to
take this the symmetric difference of
these two machines so since the M and M
prime are imagined so we will obtain a
graph we consider of disjoint cycles and
path passes then we can find well then
we can define some canonical order of
this component so say we can first to
choose these components to the cycle and
then choose the path then we have an
operation of unwinding which means we
can stay we can first choose this edge
so remember we want to
move from the red area from the red
match into the green match and we can
start from this cycle and start start
from this from red matchings and then we
can remove this we can remove this edge
and then we place this green edge by the
red edge and replace this cooling edge
by this red edge and so on so after we
finish in disc this cycle we can do the
similar theme for this path so in this
way in this canonical way we can change
from the end to an M Prime and in fact
in this way we can define a a can or a
we can define a canonical path
connecting every two pair of pairs of
matching and in fact this way this
chemical pass has a very low congestion
but I'm not going to give a detailed
analysis of this congestion but but the
the fact is this is a very good
canonical pass so we with the want to
generalize this to some other problems
so so the framework we are going to work
on is the whole problem lesson clean
previous talk we know what is a hoarding
problem so so here we we consider our
whole program from is specified by a
feminine functions so we have a instance
is a is a graph G and each vertex is
associated with a function which is in
this family so in this case we only work
on the boolean functions just like the
case of matching to each edge each other
either 0 or 1 and so for each
configuration we can define its weight
which is a product of value of the
evaluated on each vertex and then the
problem is to compute the partition
function which is the summation over all
the weight of configurations
and we are also focus on these Demetric
functions which means these functions
the value of our function f only depends
on the Hamming weight of the input okay
so for us symmetric functions of REM we
can write it in this compact form so
they r FY is the value of F on input
with Hemingway time and so for example
the the program accounting machines can
be understood as the Holland problem
with every f ways of this form so we
only allow at most of the one of its
incident edges are chosen by the by the
configuration so i'm going to introduce
the notion of wine durable functions so
this this is defined by Mac Crinan and
aimed at general right then the simple
algorithm for counting matches and so
the his detonations quite technical so
before introducing the definition of to
introduce some additional notations so
here is the notation we call the the
partition the supposed red is a set and
we have a 01 vector X defined on the the
reset J then we use script M sub X to
denote the set of partitions on the
support of X so it the definition would
be clear if you look at this example so
say in this case j is 1 2 3 4 5 and we
have a a vector X which is having value
one on position 1 3 4 5 6 the MX the
following set so each each element of MX
is a petition of the support of X into
pals and in case that the Hamming weight
of n is odd we can have at most one
single so this is definition of FX
and now we can introduce the definition
of renewable functions so the wine
double functions so he saw our this
definition to be quite technique of you
it's your first time to look at it but
it's quite a natural if you understand
what the mahkan train our window
function is going to be so let's look at
the definitions so we say a function f
is vulnerable if there exists some value
be so the value P are indexed by three
three parts of the first part is a input
X and under another input Y and a
matching em so what is M ma is a
matching in the support of X X or Y to
remember the notion we defined before
and those value B are required to
satisfy these two conditions so what
does these two conditions me so
essentially this doesn't captures the
way 11 loaded flows in a canonical part
argument so remember in the case of
matching we have a matching m and our
matching m prime and we want to
construct a canonical part from M to M
Prime the first thing to do is to come
to cook to consider the symmetric
difference of MN and prime though here
for input X and X Y we consider the
symmetric differenter of x and y and I
claim that for each em in this set it
corresponds to a canonical path from X X
to Y and the weight of this canonical
pass it's proportional to the value P XY
m and so then you look at the first
condition of the wine double so the it
is mostly identical the requirement for
a canonic
pass so this is the intuition behind the
these definitions and and the condition
to just allows us to apply a flow
encoding argument to show the low
congestion of this kind of mini coupe us
now so in this clock I'm not going to
talk about the detail of the second part
but we are many focus on why we have a
natural condition one here so this is
what we are going to do and so now
giving these conditions we we can have a
class of functions which we call a
winder bro and there we start to design
mockup chain for to sample from those
wine normal functions to in order to
work on this we we our configurations
are on the so-called half edge focus
consider a a graph we break each edge of
the graph into two half edges so to like
this and we have to we have many class
of configurations we use Omega K to
denote the set of configurations with k
inconsistent edge so in the following we
are used red edge to indicate this edge
has been adorned by the one and the
black edge s2 to indicate this edge has
been earlier value 0 so so this is a
dormant in the unique avoid
collaboration Omega 1 since we only have
this edge which is which have an
inconsistent color yes and this is a
configuration in omega-3 since we have
three war edge which has inconsistent
color
so it is clear okay and so all Markov
chain just one on the the space of Omega
0 and Omega 2 so our mark changes that
simple by a simple Metropolitan or to
move between these two between
configurations and that we only move
between configurations who's having
distances is exactly two so this rose is
the simple is the metro police room and
so it's reversible and and the converts
to learn to the desired distribution and
we have a dignus step to make this
Malcolm chain lady so we add some
probability to the state to stay at
signal so with this Markov chain
McQuillan shows that if with this Markov
chain if every function f is winnable
then this Markov chain the retinal
mixing
and as a corollary fixed our temple in
space is omega 0 iulian omega 2 so if
this Markov chain is repli mixing and we
have this additional condition that is
the the weight the ratio between the
weight of omega 2 and the widow omega 0
is bounded by some polynomial then we
can efficiently sample from the omega
there since we just need to remember the
definition of the omega k the set of
omega 0 is what we would like to temple
from so if we have this additional
condition than we have a period to
compute the potential function of this
holland problem so in order to analyze
these two dis Muk chain we can have to
look at the canonical path to find for
this chain and these wine number
functions so so those we now have two
configurations the first is from Omega 0
and a second if wrong Omega 2 and then
we can we want to define the canonical
passes from X to Y so the first step is
to take the symmetric different of these
two configurations okay so so for this
simple example so there are symmetric
difference is just the same as Y okay so
then we have so our configuration is
just our adornment on the half edge and
then remember that we climb that for
every matching every every matching on
our vertex corresponds to a canonical
pass so but these matches are defined on
each vertex so suppose now we can fix a
matching on MV for each per ticket we in
this in this graph so so in this thing I
think I have a
try to shield this matching so so
consider this vertex then the that we
have three edge so we we don't have a
formation we have a one we have a 2 2's
matched and up with the singleton edge
right so we use this blue dot dot it
edge to indicate the matched edge right
and this for this degree four vertices
we have two powers of matched vertices
so now we fix such a matching for each
vertex then we can construct a new graph
so this new graph the vertices of this
new graph is a set of half edge so the
red edge see in this graph is the
vegetative of our new graph and the edge
of the new graph consists of two parts
the first part is the blue dotted edge
is the edge in the in our fixed
merchants and the second part of of edge
this note edge connecting half edge that
is this black dotted s so then in this
way we can construct a new new graph and
it is easy to see this new global also
consists of disjoint passes and cycles
for example in this graph we have in
fact that we have two parties to first
to this edge then this edge and then
this edge and then this edge so this is
a a pass and we have another part is
this edge with this edge and we have one
cycle so this edge of this statute is
that your decision so in this example we
have to destroy in the past and the
process end of one destroying cycles and
we can also fix some canonical way
can you nanako order to unwinding these
configurations so for example we can
first choose this weekend first choose
this path and change these two
configurations and then change into
these two configurations and after
finishing this path we can start with
this cycle first a change this power of
edge and this despair and repel and
finally we change this this path so so
in this way for each fixed end merchants
on each vertex we can define a way of
reloading from the routine from X to Y
and the weight of this canonical path is
just the product of p value remember
this p value our values of witnessing
each vertex V is one double okay so this
is our definition of the canonical part
for wine more functions so in this way
so in this way if we apply the condition
the second condition of the in the
definition of the wine double functions
we can prove this condition that we can
prove this cannock path has no
congestion but if you look at this proof
you can see well the the technician of
wine double function just say just post
some conditions saying that some kind of
canonical / past argument applies but it
doesn't tell you how to decide whether
or function is decidable right so if you
want to apply the
you will not directly apply this
definition bindable / to decide whether
a function in winder but it's not very
easy and in the work of my queen and he
gives a few example of the work of wine
double function but even for some very
simple functions he need to have a very
complicated construction of this value
be so are so we study the a special
class of functions the set of Demetric
functions and we can show that at least
for this symmetric functions the wine
ability has a very simple
characterization so first consider a
symmetric function FX retain this
compact form and with the obtaining of
this function it's just a subsequence of
this this this truth table of these
functions and we say and we have a
following categorization theorem for the
for the for the symmetric functions so
with the symmetric function f is wine
double if and only if we consider every
pinnock g of s and for each pin engine
we can define our function H where H of
a trophy X is G of X times G of X bar
where x pi is opting for act by flipping
every positions so in the case that do
is the symmetric function so if X the
heavy weight of X is I then the
hemorrhoid of G bar is n minus I so for
each pin of G we can have a funky edge
and we require that for each edge this
linear equation has a long- solution so
this is a characterization of the wine
ability and so the matrix a is defined
as follows so
so so so so in fact what does this mean
so consider the entry of a IJ entry of
as a matrix I am so it has the following
component or interpretations so consider
we have a am labeled both which means
the each party friend and I of this
emboss are red and unmask I of this boss
are blue and then a IJ is just a number
of ways to petition this em both into
pills so increase that M is the odd we
we can have at most of one single terms
so a is a number of ways to partition em
into cows such that a number of health
with different colors is J so this is a
a solicitor number given and it can be
computed in this way so this is our
definition of a this is our definition
of matrix a so so with this
characterization theorem given a
function f in order to check in order to
decide whether it is wonderful we only
need to check every painting of g and
the edge obtained from g we just we need
to check whether this equation has a
non-negative solutions so i will sketch
the proof of this characterization serum
is so things we are only the source this
this term theorem only applies to
symmetric functions and so we can we can
infect the crucible observations that
for each X of Y we don't need to
consider too many value of P XY m so we
can classify matches in in the in the
partitions of X X or Y into some
equipment classes and
suppose the the Hemmingway's of X X or Y
it and then each equipment classic scalp
can be indexed buys some I and J and we
show that if a function f is one double
then they exist the family of these B
values such that for m and M prime in
the same equipment Club equipment class
these two values are the same then the
value aiga in the definition of matrix a
is just that is the number of elements
in the equivalent class indexed by a I
and J so in this way we can reduce the
task of fine of finding some the value
be XY m into the task of solving a
system of linear equations and we just
take we just take the solution X as our
value for this be so we requirement for
this X is that they are all non-negative
so with this tool we can help long
examples the first is the matching
functions to matching is the function of
this form and if we want to apply our
correlation theorem we only look at in
the painting of g and the edge obtained
from g so for functions of this form the
the probability of edge are only only
three so we only look at these three
simple functions and to check the a
one-time x equal to 1 and a 2 times x
equal to 0 1 have non-negative solutions
and the disease can be easily done and
for the second condition so so remember
in the in the in either corollary of
mcqueen's film we need another condition
that is the weight that the ratio
between the weight of omega 2 and the
omega 0 is bounded by a polynomial and
this it also seemed very simple from for
this for the example of matchings
so given this is though given these two
equation is the solution of this two
equations we we can conclude that there
is periodic for continuity's and the
second example is the the the so-called
subcraft world so the subgroup word was
introduced by Jeremy Sinclair to
approximate the protein function of VC
model and it is in fact a hole in the
problem with parity contract so in each
vertex the constraint is of the form 1
mu 1 mu four mu for some non negative mu
so if we look at this kind of funky F
and the pinion faith and edge obtained
from g there are two probabilities
depends on the are the parity of the the
parity of g the first one is the all one
function the technology say also
operating functions and it is also very
easy to check we can for a general
version for function of this form we can
solve our equations and we can we can
check this faith wine double so at least
with this with this characterization we
can say that at least for the case mu is
positive we have FP rot for the sub
graph would so force apology you also
have a head wages a very clean edge
weight later
and so did so we have known these two
epiros before and now i'm going to talk
about some new examples new algorithm so
the first is the permanent be matching
so given a graph G and and the problem
would be matching is we say a
configuration tab interchanged affair if
for every week at most be of this
incident edged are chosen ok so the the
matching problem is is the one matching
right so if we write it as a holding
problem then the constraint are of this
form so so we can apply our theorem to
check for what be this problem is
wonderful and for every constant be the
the opinion of this function only have
constant a number of probabilities so
you only need to check a constant number
of linear equations to see whether the
function is wonderful and we can show
that be matching the wind about if and
only if piece at most seven
and similar we have the ratio bound and
so we have the four be at most even the
problem of counting be merchants have a
half kilos and the second example is the
so-called be edge covers so edge covers
which is so for every budget v we have a
tallit p of this incident edge that
chosen by sigma so in the case of
merchants and we have advil to be and in
the case of Edgecam we have at least be
so in this way we can also we can also
have the author apply our Caravan
regimes theorem and we can obtain the
following without so the big problem of
bh cover its wine double if and only
have be that monster too so we have that
the be matching for be equal to one or
two they'll say FP r us and we have and
so for all the f drug we mentioned we
have the following week an intended them
to the edge weighted version since we
get just sub divide each edge and we add
a constraint 10 and the weight of e to
these vertices and since this function
or the winder was so we can actually add
the edge weight to each edge so all
previous f-prot can be extended to the
edge which devotions as known as the the
ratio between that led to that to
configure class of convolution is
bounded so this is our this literally
the epcot we obtained from this method
and now i'm going to talk about some
footwork in this nine the first days can
we say the decide the wind ability for
some other holding the programs so we
are focusing on the whole problem with
the bully domain so the a class of
we have completed if the free college
gate that is the functions satisfying
this recurrence and remember that the
parity function is a special case when c
is equal to 0 and we can show in fact
these cuts of function is to bind a book
for sufficiently small C and so this is
the the deal is I think the the
increased question is too can we
identify some other class of pudding
Holland problem which is winnable and
they can design f-prot for this using
this tool and the second point is that
the wind ability and the magic eight so
mcqueen improve the following theorem
about the win ability and the match gate
it's just that if we consider all the
functional realizable by Medicaid here a
match gauge it's not a nice area planner
and it can use the console window of the
matching and the perfect matching this
showed he showed that every function
realizable by this Medicaid our wine
double and he also showed the converse
the converse direction of this theorem
for talking with Erica atmosphere so
which means for all the function with
Raj at motor sweet it is1 double if and
only if it can be realizable by this
kind of educate so the question is
whether for the for the for the function
with higher already can we still have
these directions so in fact this term
gives a way to check whether a given
function is can be realizable can be
realized by a Medicaid of this form so
for example we have shown that the eight
matching is is not my noble so using
this theorem we can say that the item
the eight matching problem
the eight matching function cannot be
realized to buy a match gate of this
form so so I think it is very
interesting to investigate the converse
director of this theorem and we are not
able to prove for so it except using the
definition of readability we are not
able to show some function it's not a
real item really is the kind cannot be
realized by Python match k to be we
don't have any tour to achieve this so I
think so in order to prove or disprove
this we need some new technique to
understand these functions and let it
so I kind of wonder is this one bit of a
preserved by X a holographic
transformations because if i remember
correctly filmmagic is our equivalent up
two orthogonal transformations but
different see now here you are saying I
could only for small series wonderful
alarm say exactly not right reservations
yes so so I think there's no rhythm 241
ability to be preserved on the list
reduction this is not necessarily wear
it underneath
language there I don't know so in fact
we have twice my noble function and we
try to realize them by using some magic
eight but for something we can we can or
can construct such a magic eight so
you're not annoying edge weights
are we allow the positive edge wit ya
there is it so in fact we know that song
some function like equality we cannot it
is not a wine double and it cannot be
realized by by Medicaid with positive
with owning positive wait
to achieve action with thousand we
believe that the be matching is always
approachable but are not using this
method
and its native speaker